hey everybody welcome to the great big
story youtube channel i'm jillian i'm
dave welcome to the show
here at great big story we love food so
this entire weekend we have some of our
favorite food stories we're gonna start
in england and we're gonna meet a guy
who grows really really big veggies
really big check it out
[Music]
good day
we can grow giant models
four foot in a month
um 45 inches
these models would taste exactly the
same as a normal model
nice and tender and lush some of them
look a bit tough but once you cut into
them they cut like butter
my name is philip vals i live in lanari
wales and i grow giant vegetables
[Music]
i've been growing giant vegetables now
for the last 30 years
i come from a very large family my
mother had 17 children
13 of us survived and i think you know
that was something you know big
vegetables feed big families
you know i'm up here every morning every
night every single day of the week
there's a lot of love and care goes into
it
sometimes i do a bit of talking to them
as well
to encourage them to grow which is a bit
of you know a bit of fun
you know i think he's just about
finished growing there now i got to be
very careful the wife is not about when
i start talking to my vegetables but
it's all good fun
i broke the world record for the
heaviest cucumber about 25 years ago it
weighed 18 and a half pound and it was
just incredible the way it grew
you know when i started if we had a
model
20 30 pounding weight you had a big
model now we're up over a hundred pound
in weight
a normal cabbage would be
two pounding weights
while we are growing them 120 pounds you
know you can feed
120 130 140 people off one cabbage
this is why i supply the local pub
and they use them up for sunday lunch
i've developed my own strain more or
less now
i select my own seed every year
the biggest and the best seed and it
just seems to be improving
which is incredible
i grow organically i think if i can do
it anybody can do it
and it's a big thrill every day
the wife said what am i doing up the lot
what every day
and when she comes up she realizes
it isn't people who just have to eat
animals have to eat too we're gonna head
over to the oakland zoo and meet stacy
who is the zoo chef there check it out
i cook for warthogs emu lions tigers
hyenas spoonbill sun bear flamingo and
giraffe
they can be very picky
[Music]
every morning i'm preparing around 350
pounds of food my name is stacy kyles
and i prepare the food for the animals
at the oakland zoo i'm also known as the
zoo chef
[Applause]
my day starts off very early before the
sun even comes up
i've got to get the food for the animals
or we have nothing to prepare showers
across northern california the calm
before the storm of getting to the
market i need to get about a ton of food
today
literally
the produce market's kind of hectic
you've got a lot of forklifts running
back and forth you've got trucks
everywhere
there's a lot to choose from
i have to stay organized or this can get
very overwhelming i've got a huge market
that i've got to go through i've got to
pick out the right produce so i have a
limited amount of time at the market
because i have to get back here to
prepare the diets
[Music]
i open the door to the kitchen and then
i know my day has truly begun
[Music]
sun bears
48 grams apple
quantum monday three hard-boiled eggs
lions
ten bones and five ounces of grapes off
the vine seven servings two whole 60
grams of crickets one drop vitamin 44
the zoo itself as a whole prepares about
a thousand diets a day so that's
anywhere from the elephants down to the
leaf cutter ants and all the little
reptiles and all the little frogs
[Music]
it's important that we get the diets
right because the animals can't send the
food back they can't tell us oh i don't
like this
we don't take days off
everything still has to happen the food
gets prepared exactly the same way every
single day i tried telling them it was
christmas once they didn't pay attention
[Music]
do you like sushi i do
have you ever had grasshopper sushi
can't say that i have
well there is a chef and he's making
sushi just like that and he's making it
really sustainable let's check it out
it makes perfect sense for us to be
eating invasive species because invasive
species are an endless
resource for food
my name is bun lai i'm the chef at mia's
sushi in new haven 33 years ago my
mother started mia's reimagining sushi
as something that is restorative of the
environment
this is part of the regimen that happens
every day in the morning foraging
one of the things that we're really
focused on is invasive species what if
we start focusing on ingredients that
nobody else wants to eat that are
abundant and even destructive of the
environment and by pulling them out of
the environment will help rebalance that
habitat
this is wild lettuce
and we're going to serve them with bug
holes in them it's like swiss cheese
that means that they're they're healthy
to eat and that they're pesticide
herbicide free
here's a big one
really can't hesitate you have to be
fully committed to catch him and see if
i am
gotcha
you're a lot stronger than you
think he's really pushing off my hand
yeah we're set to go let's rock and roll
[Music]
great
these snails from europe they're called
european snails came over
stuck on ships
i feel like you're like a big kid just
crawling around looking under rocks
when i'm collecting it's always
incredibly exciting it's very thrilling
for me well all right
but when i'm trying to figure out new
ways of working with an ingredient that
i've never worked with before or an
ingredient that actually grosses me out
i like the fact that i'm forcing myself
to
confront my own prejudices
today we went foraging for dandelion
amaranth
wild lettuce mugwort
butterbur
grasshopper invasive european snails a
whole bunch of asian shore crabs and
juakami seaweed and gracilaria seaweed
[Music]
are you gonna be mad if we show the
whole world that you can make gourmet
sushi just using stuff in your backyard
that's what we want the whole world to
do or consider doing or think about
doing and not only that this isn't an
original idea people have been doing
this for tens of thousands hundreds of
thousands of years way before before
mias and it's delicious and it's
absolutely delicious and nutritious
and great for the environment
our next story comes from the far-off
land of queens new york at a hindu
temple
and you might see a familiar face in
this video
watch out for it
on the surface the ganesha temple in
queens seems like just a place of
worship for hindus
hi
but if you take the side entrance down
the hall with all the lights follow the
signs down the stairs follow more signs
down more stairs you'll find
the temple canteen a restaurant serving
food to rival anything you would find in
india
[Music]
this is dr uma maisourikar namaste i am
the president of the hindu temple
society of north america in flushing new
york
the temple came into existence in 1977
and as one of the first of its kind in
north america the temple has become a
cultural hub for hindus throughout the
u.s this is a place like home people who
come to the temple spend their whole day
here they have their worshiping services
in the morning and then very often we
have cultural programs but also they
come here to eat they come to the temple
to eat yes they do come here to eat some
of them come just only to eat not even
to come inside the temple
so in addition to a place of worship a
community center and a wedding venue the
ganesha temple serves cuisine authentic
to south india and is open to the public
and the food is pretty fantastic just
ask the new york times or new york
magazine or anthony bourdain this is
delicious it's not easy to find
indian food everywhere around the
corners so people come to find authentic
indian food
okay so if you don't know anything about
south indian food here are some of the
must-haves
there's vara i always call that as a
salty donuts idli it is nothing but
puffed rice
somber it is made of lentils very
healthy and most notably dosas there are
at least about eight or nine kinds of
dosas it consists of dao and there is a
filling inside we have about an
authentic indian cooks
in our hinduism we strongly believe
without the offering of food to the
deities our prayer is incomplete and
that's how it really started
but i think when you go to a canteen or
a restaurant you want to enjoy your food
we want to make sure
that whether it is a hindu or a
non-hindu should be able to enjoy the
food
who cares really whether it is an indian
restaurant or a non-indian restaurant
you just want to go and eat food so the
next time you're hungry in queens try
the temple
[Music]
thanks everybody for joining us and
watching these four great big stories
click the horse to subscribe and leave a
comment below
see you next time bye guys cheers
you